well that is the question isn't it
Donald Trump is now laid down his vision
for the future but will it be winning
over American voters let's bring in
Richard Walker who's in Cleveland for us
right now Richard it's been a very long
night for you as Donald Trump said how
he's going to make America great again
well it was still very much a kind of
broad brush speech even though I mean he
did go through an awful lot of areas
talking about security talking about the
economy those is the kind of two chief
areas of concern for him it really
didn't get down to an awful lot of
detail about how he was going to
kick-start the economy beyond the kind
of thing that we've heard from him
before for instance that he wants to
increase a fossil fuel discovery to get
any more energy into the economy that
sort of thing that he wants to cut taxes
but at the same time he says he wants to
increase investment in roads
infrastructure and that sort of thing so
there's a lot of fact-checking going on
right now people beavering away to sort
of see whether his Psalms add up some of
the claims that he's made have added up
but I would say it was still pretty
broad brush it was still very much the
kind of thing that he's based his
campaign on all along really which is
really about aspirations and a kind of
stance that he wants to have in a world
of American greatness of restoring an
imagined greater time in American
history rather than going into the kind
of sort of borrowed down detail that you
get from Hillary Clinton go on her
website and she's got reams and reams of
pages of policy proposals still nothing
like that from Donald Trump what about
the tone of this speech Richard one of
its goals certainly was to present a
Donald Trump who's presidential
yeah well it was interesting it sort of
fell in between Donald Trump's usual
kind of off the cuff style and his
teleprompter reading Stan usually his
teleprompter speeches have been very
stiff he's obviously not very
comfortable reading from a prompter this
time he was reading from a prompter but
he seemed distinctly happier with it he
did riff sometimes of sentences at his
own little pair asians here and there
and that gave it a bit more of a sort of
half-and-half feel compared to his
previous empty efforts to read from a
teleprompter so really did feel like him
coming across I think also the speech
writing was improved compared to
previous teleprompter speeches you often
got them essentially he was being
force-fed lines by a speech writer that
he wasn't really comfortable saying and
this was written mostly an extremely
simple language the kind of language
that he likes to use when he is speaking
off the cuff and the kind of language
that has really kind of got it's really
got his message through to an awful lot
of people on the campaign trail this
made his campaign such a success Richard
had that that message go down with the
delegates out on the floor what was the
mood when he laid down the law and order
message for example yeah well it was
very positive and it was a speech that
was very long but it was interesting
that you didn't get a sense that the
crowd was was sort of running out of
energy or getting bored at any time
there were huge applause lines in there
especially the law and order sort of
stuff also the attacks on Hillary
Clinton and we were speaking just behind
me here there's a stage there was a band
playing after the speech we were
speaking to delegates and other
Republican Party members there who
celebrating after speech getting a sense
of what they thought of the speech and
it was quite interesting what they had
to say so what do we just play tape of
that now he is my boy see he knows what
I'm going to like I totally believe
Stan's what's going on over I believe
I'm somebody that's come from supporting
a different candidate Donald Trump was
by 17th choice and now he's number one
numero uno I thought was amazing I am a
gay American so I was so happy to hear
him shout out from the podium I believe
that's the first time a candidate has
sort of spoken to our community in that
way from either party certainly for a
Republican I wasn't really a big fan of
the kind of rhetoric that was coming out
of the Trump campaign but it was really
great to see and that was kind of walk
back during the convention I thought it
was a great speech and I thought it was
a speech that he really needed to give
tonight to show people that he's
presidential and can deliver a speech
with the gravitas that's necessary for
that office I think was a very good
speech uniting speech a speech of a lot
of promises now we do hope that they
will be able to fulfill I'm is duly
impressed because I think he brought the
chatter down and you spoke to the
problems that we have in our country in
a very serious manner
so you see I mean the people there
obviously one or two of them had had one
or two drinks but i think it was quite a
sink talking to all those people and
others people who we didn't put on on
camera that they were really uniformly
impressed by the speech but in different
ways so you had some people have been
Trump supporters all along who heard
exactly what they'd been hoping to you
we also spoke a lot of people who had
come from other candidates like the
woman we just heard there Donald Trump
was hurt 17th choice the last person she
imagined herself supporting on there in
the Republican field which was 17 people
strong last summer and saying that she'd
come around and also I think it was
interesting to hear from the young gay
man there that was also quite a
distinctive thing that Donald Trump you
know he's often seen as a very sort of a
hardliner particularly from outside the
United States inside the United States
on these social issues like gay rights
is actually pretty moderate and that was
quite a telling shout out to the gay
community that he that he had there in
his speech okay so he's looking to make
the big tent even bigger for the
republican party apparently Richard we
have to leave it there Richard Walker
for us and in Cleveland thanks very much
for sure